you know that really really tall girl
that you go to school with but you maybe
you wanna well that's me 16 years old 6
foot one and a half well how's the
weather up there nice sweat pants that
squats why'd you say to my best friend a
furrier please honey you just have to be
strong in the face of adversity oh I
love it
that's the one you're perfect I just
think it's crazy you won't date a short
guy you really think that at any moment
so I'm taller than you perfect guy is
just gonna walk through that door
[Music]
okay
you are
of course I'm not the guy got out of
customs what an hour ago and she's
already marking her territory
hey like in America so far I'm liking
America very much so far
one day Jodee you're gonna stand up and
say I love all 73 inches of myself I was
hoping you'd wanna go with me to the
homecoming test yeah yeah sure sure I
mean gotcha
let's face it Jody here the tall girl I
just want you to feel done every time
you try to make me feel more normal you
just end up making me feel like more of
a freak I I need your help little sister
I've been waiting for this day to come
my entire life I'm going to extreme
makeover the crap out of you let's get
to work you should so you're telling me
that a lip gloss and lip glass are stop
stressing
I look like grandma's couch or a
beautiful mermaid princess now this is
me I like new Jody face your fears Jody
going after what you want Jody I've been
in love with this girl since elementary
school this new guys lows up my plan
[Music]
you're moving in on my man no not stay
away from it I will stop agree with
everything I'm saying okay oh we've all
got something about ourselves we wish we
could change you're not big little
sister that's me the only thing that we
can control is how we deal with it when
you're a tall girl it's it's the only
thing that people see it's not the only
thing I see I just want to make sure
that you don't get hurt
you